very uncomfortable with that picture
right now
no one does pda quite like michael b
jordan and laurie harvey okay why ain't
mad at that y'all ain't mad but now
lori's dad steve harvey is dishing on
how all that public affection makes him
feel i won't listen to her with social
media i can't participate in it like her
on tuesday the 65 year old comedian
makes a stop by the ellen degeneres show
and when ellen pulls up this pic of his
25 year old daughter sitting on the
black panther star's lap steve well
he wasn't feeling it
look at that that's happening in front
of you
i've never seen that picture before
very uncomfortable with that picture
right there i'm not
really feeling that picture and while
steve may not be feeling that picture
he's had a year to get on board with
their romance the couple celebrated
their one year anniversary back in
november i'm trying not to smile so hard
right now and when e.t sat down with the
just mercy star last year he opened up
about their love what does michael b
jordan find very sexy i think a sense of
humor
i think you know the ability to laugh
you know that infectious feeling i think
is i think is really really sexy so a
smile a nice smile and a laugh and a
sense of humor is uh is really sexy to
me well i see why you found who you
found then because she has all of those
all those things absolutely actually
very funny a lot of people don't know
that about she yeah she's really funny
and things are going so well between
them michael even spent christmas with
lori and her fam for the second time
this is his second christmas with us
yeah
is he a good gift giver hell yeah
that's why i like him
so he bought me this
big uh 100
uh cigar box of the most
most uh hard to get cigars 100 of them
in this big box and gave that to me he
gave my wife some skis who do that
only way you give your potential
mother-in-law some skis is cause you
want her to be your mother-in-law so
does michael have steve's blessing i
think i'm a pretty lovable guy actually
i'm pulling for him cause he's a really
good guy man comes from a good family
you know
i saw him kind of pulling for him but at
the same time i'm just i got my eye on
him you know
i can't whoop him but if he ever turn
around i'm gonna knock his ass out
[Applause]
that boy being in jail man like he comes
in my gym to work out and i'll be going
like whoa
i'm impressed i wasn't going for like
the the ripped boxer look i kind of
wanted to be more you know just beefier
heavier more more more intimidating and
all that echoes what the family feud
host told et back in september
this guy is is not a representative
he is genuinely who he who he looks like
he is i mean like it threw me off at
first because he was so kind
you know i figured okay this is the game
right
but it wasn't man this dude was sincere
and he's proven to be a really really
good good guy man i mean look i'm
pulling for him you know i'm pulling for
them
also impressive the surprise birthday
party the 34 year old actor threw for
lori last week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and although michael couldn't attend he
did make sure the skincare entrepreneur
was surrounded by her closest
girlfriends including normani and ryan
destiny
super proud of that then on thursday
lori shared on instagram that her family
threw her a last-minute party which
michael was able to attend i'm just
genuinely excited he also posted this
sweet video on instagram for laurie's
birthday
i
while that catch was pretty impressive
it's what michael wrote in the caption
that really had fans swooning quote
happy b day to my turtle my favorite
part nine crime
[Music]
you